oh what way we were so wrong how much
better is the 15 Pro Max's cameras than
the 14 and 13 Pro Maxes right here we
have a bunch of photos that Max took
today and we haven't seen any of them so
far and our job is to figure out which
one was taken by the 15 Pro Max to see
what kind of progress there is so this
is the first photo it is a standard
portrait shot all right I'm I'm finding
a difference right away I think the 15
is the left one first of all because of
the HDR are with the color of the truck
kind of being revealed as this yellowish
compared to really kind of flattened in
Gray on the other two so left one I
think I'm also seeing more like
definition and highlight roll off on her
face in the left one compared to say the
right one so I think I'm going to go
with the left as well and you guys are
correct that is the 15 now you guys go
ahead and play along with us let's see
does the iPhone 15 camera is it always
the best or not we're going to have a
variety of photos here is the second
shot here it's definitely not the left
one that looks absolutely terrible
between the center and the right it's
actually really close but I'm going with
the right one I'm going to go with the
center one you're going oh yeah I'm
going I think there's more on the right
but let's see all right oh I was wrong V
chose a 14 pro Max and that's okay what
the sensors on the 40 megapixels are
identical for the 14 and 15 whereas the
13 Pro Max is a 12 dang here's the next
one oh right one instantly definitely
the right one yeah oh wow that's by far
the cleanest now you guys know that the
new 15 has a 5x lens the 14 and 13
they're both 3x so let's see nice you
guys got it right and it's surprising
how these two cameras are actually
identical Hardware Wise It's just
software difference here is the next one
it's a portrait I mean I like this H I
like the center I'm kind of noticing uh
less blown out highlights like here the
right one is very I don't know the right
one doesn't look fully in Focus but the
center one looks like there's more blur
and more separation in the depth you
guys are right that is the 15 Pro Max
and the 14 looked really weird that
compression that's what yeah 5x lens
compression and here is a standard shot
in tough lighting this is difficult they
all look very similar I think the one on
the right is probably the 13 and between
these I think the 15 is the left one I
would say so as well because you have
really nice highlights up in the sky but
everything here is brought up as well so
it's very balanced I like it okay oh wow
no way we were so wrong how did that
even happen I was the right one the 15
yeah what happened there huh it looks
different these two look more similar
wow this one looks different here now
the interesting thing is the 15 does a
24 megapix standard photo compared to 12
from a 48 and then just and here here is
our next shot I think I'm seeing the
most detail on the left image I'm going
to go with the right left and right and
this is a zoom photo Zoom photo they're
all at
5x oh n Angelica got that right bade
chose the 3x lens that's digitally
zoomed in to five yeah yeah I was
surprised the difference is there but
it's not massive what do you think about
this one o I'm seeing a lot of noise
here I'm not liking that as well the
center one's definitely the sharpest
yeah I think so if you look at these
textures yeah Center one the center one
yeah and that is what is going on what
happened no something went wrong here
yeah it's worse nothing went wrong this
is Apple's design because the 13 Pro Max
you can actually Focus close to a
subject whereas the other two they have
to switch to ultra wide okay in order to
do so and that actually comes up often
if you want to take a close-up shot shot
now some people could back up you could
do different zooms to help with this um
but in a lot of third party apps for
example if you need to send a picture of
your ID they don't have modes or
anything so a lot of times you're stuck
and it won't even scan which is what
I've come up to now here is the next
shot this of course is a portrait shot
wow it's immediately the left for me
yeah if you look at this coat look at
every little tiny fiber insane quality
here I'm seeing a lot more compression
in the background as well
really nice so both you guys voted for
the left and the color differences too
you guys were right um the smart HDR 5
looks a lot more natural in the face
even with the HDR it looks really good
here's another one here this is very
tough like I would have to pixel peep
cuz right now I don't know they're very
similar it's so tough so two of these
phones could do a 2X portrait while the
other one you are forced to crop I think
I like the right image the most I would
have to agree I just got closer and
pixel peeped I'm going for the right I
see more detail that is a 15 Pro Max and
it's interesting that the 13 Pro Max
still looks great even though you have
to crop and I love that 2x mode I use it
all the time on the new phones here is a
photo well it's definitely I don't want
say too much not the left one yeah it's
not the left one for sure I'm going with
the center yeah me too I just looked at
kind of like the detail on the trees
looks better detail here this little
crack yeah Center one I think I was
surprised by how close these two are you
guys are right that is the 15 Pro Max
and once again even though both of these
have the same Hardware M big difference
the 13 is not good we have a selfie here
all these are 12 megapixel there's a lot
of detail in that Center image ton of
detail in the faces while V is pixel
peeping here what I want to say is that
I'm surprised by how well all of these
do very close and Apple has actually
done software updates over time to make
the the older phones better I'm going to
go with the left man I'm going to go
with the left I don't know let's
see got the 15 it's a very slight HDR
difference I just saw that it's kind of
more blown out in the sky that's the
only reason true but the sharpness is
basically the same and we have this cow
try I mean it's the center right I think
it's the center that looks the best to I
think it is the center just look at all
these little patches of fur here plus
the leaves looks a lot more detailed
than the other two and this one's really
flat too and you guys got it correct now
the 15 Pro Max does a 24 megapixel image
instead of 12s and it does look better
nice this one's a lot more obvious this
one's very obvious you can definitely
tell from the focal length difference of
all the compression with the 5x lens yep
and then these are not crops this is
coming closer to your subject like you
would and I got to say this is my
favorite thing with these new phones
those 5x portraits that Androids don't
DOA looks awesome amazing wa here we got
a selfie with a sunset I mean it's got
to be the right one right don't they
have like an anti-glare coating that's
supposed to be a lot better I mean it
sucks it has this line through it in
your middle of your face but I'm going
to actually go with the center image
because of the HDR over here oh Angelica
HDR oh can I change can I change mine
now no it's too late are you sure you're
right got it right fine fine I won't
change it so if you guys notice here we
have this streak right got a little
better than 13 13 has a bunch of streaks
15 no streaks but you do have a little
bit of hazy ha yeah um but the HDR I
mean finally better HDR for portraits
here we have an image of these apples
first thing I noticed that this is all
white on the right one oh good point HDR
is terrible on that one but the other
two are very very similar I I like the
center if I'm looking close at all the
leaves and details there and like the
Highlight rollof on the apples too I I
like that I'm actually going to go with
the left one I see more detail on that
one so we got Center and
left chose the 13 Pro how I get the 13
prox what happened to the 14 am I
tripping so this is an interesting
scenario wow um because I want to take a
shot like this the 15 Pro Max you have
to use the 5x these you have a 3X so the
15 Pro Max has to do a crop from its
main sensor whereas these don't I don't
know why the 14 pro Max did a worse job
but 13 looks great we have a cool shot
here yeah it's probably the center one
huh yeah look at the Cent first of all
you have more compression but look at
the hair look at her shirt you see every
single line of fiber and texture yeah
not only is that cutout really good the
detail everything is way better
difference I tried not to do a lot of 5x
portraits but I mean this is an amazing
part of the phone W sunset time I mean
as this one boom look at that glow all
of it it plus you don't have all of this
stuff wow Apple actually did a good job
getting rid of this flaring yeah this is
something not a lot of camera
comparisons even look at but this is a
real life scenario people love sunsets
and looks Apple did a great job with the
Coatings and to fix all these crazy
circles finally wow yeah we have the
sunset shot here W left one left one
yeah you definitely see better much
better HDR here yeah it looks kind of
like what you see with your eye instead
of having those blown out portions wow
man you guys are good but the camera
differences are actually especially in
the processing is more than I expected
wow shot that looks awesome and my first
thought was the left just without
looking too closely well I just did some
pixel peeping and I might be totally
wrong but I'm going for the right so
left and right oh interesting VI chose
the 13 the worst
one dang the HDR his arm I didn't look
at that B's looking at detail
dang and on your phone you don't notice
detail as much you still do than on
larger screens but yes the 15 Pro Max
now does 24 megapixel portraits compared
to 12 I was just looking at his hat I
don't know so here's a shot tell me what
you guys may or may not see these are
very close I feel like in terms of the
dark portions you see more on the left
image and these two look identical yeah
I think I'd have to agree I definitely
love all the warmer colors on the left
as well and the sky also looks like it's
producing the best colors that one is
the 15 Pro Max I the way I arrang these
I was trying to trip you guys up but
it's not working very well um and this
one is actually a panorama oh okay not a
lot of people test that but these are
panoramas with all three and then I
cropped into that section of them so
they have gotten better as well which
they didn't for many years mhm here we
have a selfie after Sunset it was quite
dark actually the best one looks like
it's the center I mean just from a
detail standpoint because you have
motion blur here the right one also
seems a little soft for some reason
facial texture smooth out so Center
looks the best defin and you guys got
that correct I think the HDR is better
on the 13 Pro Max wow wow um but look at
that noise though there is noise there
too and the interesting thing is these
two phones the 14 and 15 they have the
same hardware and it looks like Apple's
taking the pictures quicker to help with
motion blur we have this campfire photo
I think detail wise the center image
definitely looks better I think so too
yeah looking up close you definitely see
better detail and sharpness okay so you
guys what for Center what about colors
the right one is very weird it looks
like it took out all the warmth from the
fire and it just looks so bizarre yeah
you can't tell it's a campfire you like
look at the ground still going for the
center because if you see her face is
all red and like you don't really get
much roll off or Shadows where there you
do you guys voted for the 14 pro MX so
the 15 so this is another scenario where
um this is 3x on all 3x and in this
situation I'm sitting in my chair it
wasn't done on purpose but 5x is too
close I tried actually to do 5x first it
didn't look good 3x digitally went up to
3x so so this is well you hit the 3x
button or actually no maybe Zoom have 3x
you zoom in on those I hid it and looked
great uh but in this scenario it's
cropping from the main sensor and it
doesn't look good so sometimes with the
15 you will get worse photos unless you
can move back and yeah here we have
night time it was really dark this is
actually standing on a tripod too but
all the timings were the same I'm kind
of digging the center uh mostly for the
detail I'm looking at all this brush and
everything I'm digging the center one
for the detail yeah for me it was easily
the center even though I might like the
colors of the right one more you can see
these little things they're like fully
in where it got rid of them on the other
ones all these clouds back here yep and
then this is all mush we here it's
really sharp and that is the 15 Pro Max
once again same Hardware just different
processing who and we have a sky shot
this one's going oh this one's obvious I
mean for me it's got to be the right
because look tons of gray noise this is
blue but it's got more noise and what
what artifacts whatever right you could
see like three four or five times more
stars yeah yeah look at the amount of
stars and this is actually it's not on a
tripod this is this is handheld Ben
actually took this shot oh really these
are all handheld and look at the stars
and everything you see it is amazing and
yes maybe I should have click that first
yes that is the 15 Pro Max I was shocked
so this is a handheld ultra low light
that's a big difference yeah huge
difference instantly the left is that
with the same Hardware same exact
sensors identical sensors here of course
so the software the 13 Pro Max um that's
a massive difference in just what two
years yeah we have this shot Center this
is an ultra wide you can tell the center
difference wow that's the same Hardware
too same Ultra wide camera same camera
same Ultra so for people that were
saying that you know nothing has changed
other than 5x and I was one of them
being skeptical I mean this proves me
wrong cuz the center 15 Pro Max even
though the ultra wies are identical so
much sharper we have Elon here he's been
asking go fishing it's a 1x portra yeah
1X portrait here these are very similar
yeah they do look quite similar yeah
this one is really tough between the
left and the right but I did some pixel
peeping I'm pretty sure it's the right I
hope I'm not wrong I'm pretty sure it's
the right too no way we got it WR how
did we get that wrong what I know I was
shocked no way I would have agreed as as
well now when it's really dark both of
these Record 12 megap files anyways and
of course more pixels more noise so it
brings it down 13 Pro Max looks great
wow here we have a photo of Elon this is
tough too I mean here I don't like the
Grain and the noise in his jacket but if
you look at his face and his hair it
does look like there's more detail there
and this one and guys this was almost P
oh man they're very very very similar I
think yeah I don't
know you might have to just choose I
think I'm going to have to go with the
left because you can see there's a
difference in detail and his pants and
stuff yeah I guess so too so left for
you guys yeah that is the 14 pro less
detail W more noise yeah but more detail
less detail but almost no noise which is
what I noticed on my six so maybe it
softened it right interesting Yeah the
more noise reduction of softer gets no
ruction yeah and we have his fish that
he caught Center Center what okay all
right how did that happen 13 Pro Max is
this off focus Mis Focus nope they're
all focused this isn't the other
scenario where you sure the other two
switch to the ultra wide oh you did that
oh okay yep and what happens here is you
can't use the 3x or the 5x you got this
was like almost pitch dark oh wow and if
you start cropping in from the main
sensor and going back out the quality
also goes down a lot where you know here
this the ultra actually did the best on
those instead of all the cropping and
the 13 doesn't have to do any cropping
or zooming mhm here we have a very dark
shot this was actually like a 10sec
night mode shot definitely not the right
that one does the worst by far between
the left and the
center I think I got to give it to the
center it's definitely the center you
can see the grass uh everything right
there no what no way that looks the
center is the best image it's the best
how is the 13 getting a better image
than the 15 so this is uh I think this
is 10x Zoom if I remember correctly and
it is also 10c exposure what I couldn't
believe it myself like the HDR what this
is the worst this looks pretty bad some
of this looks better the trees but this
is but not that and we have this
beautiful night shot this was also I
think a 10-second exposure main lens
definitely not the right one the right
one is the most crushed in terms of
detail I think I'm liking the center one
I like the center one yeah 15 Pro Max it
does look better we have this portrait
shot harsh lighting dark I like the
center I think I see the most detail in
the center in her jacket and her face
the other two look kind of soft yeah I
agree oh Max these two are very similar
simar this crazy dark shot like I
couldn't even see we had to walk with
the flashlight there's a lot more detail
in the right image yep I agree yeah
looking at the little logos on the boat
and everything yeah and you can actually
it's brighter overall too yeah and that
is the 15 we legit couldn't walk without
a flashlight at this point it's handheld
crazy this shot right here portrait I'm
going with the right I like the overall
colors there's a lot less noise even
though the sharpness isn't the best yeah
it does look like the most clean image
very clean and that is a 15 so yeah 5x
portrait versus 3x and me getting closer
MH and I believe this is the last one 1X
nighttime portrait I think I'm going to
go with the right one I really like the
detail and I like how the white balance
is really accurate for the car and
everything there's less noise and grain
I don't know I'm actually going to go
with the left one okay let's go right
and left
oh all right I got chose the and that is
the last one so you guys comment down
below let us know if anybody surprised
you your thoughts if if a particular
shot just shocked you and um let's go
ahead and see what we got all right
starting with me I got actually eight
for the 13 Pro Max six for the 14 pro
Max 21 for the 15 Pro Max and I got five
for the 13 four for the 14 and 26 for
the wow so Angelica is actually the only
one who did not upgrade to the 15 Pro
lineup but she got it I'm going to
return
this uh but clearly it did better
overall and what's interesting is that
you guys had less points for the 14 pro
Max than the 13 Pro Max yeah 13 got more
points and interesting Apple has been
upd it was by it's because of the crop
with ultra wide when you got too close
and it couldn't focus so it switched to
the other those two of the shots those
were the sh yeah all right guys well
thank you for watching go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there and we will see you in
the next
[Music]
one